donc les petites bêtes elles sont
arrivées vous avez vu pour filer un
petit peu pour les autres ce sont les
stars du jour les tritons ce petit
amphibien de la famille des salamandres
se trouve dans les mares le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
propose aux enfants d'aller à la
découverte de cet environnement et de
leurs habitants un milieu qui est tout
proche de chez eux et bien souvent ils
ne connaissent pas du tout est belle ce
qu'on aimerait bien conclure à la fin de
sa tignasse de cette animation
c'est qu'ils se rendent compte du
foisonnement de vie qui peut et qui peut
exister dans un dans une petite surface
d'eau comme celle ci la diversité des
espèces des déplacements de la manière
de se nourrir de la manière de chasser
de la manière de respirer
têtards larves de salamandre de
libellules ou deux cas l'opt rx d
animaux plus ou moins connus qui ont
fait sensation auprès des plus jeunes
autre vedette de la journée
la larve de d'éthique qui ressemble à
une sorte de crevettes baala que qui est
déjà enlève la queue fourchue est baladé
petit crochet devant je me suis dit nafi
sayyed est ce que je connaissais pas son
nom mais sinon ça ressemblait un peu un
scorpion je trouve un petit scorpion
simple annen forme des mandibules et du
coup on a rempli leur enseignement
j'aime et que je fasse l'atelier conte
apprennent des choses changent un peu et
oui mais un moment de sensibilisation à
la protection de la faune et de la flore
l'animation se termine par la remise en
liberté des petites bêtes
d'autres visites en mai et engins sont
prévues pour les enfants mais aussi pour
les adultes